brendan why don't you just set out
exactly what people that may not have
been paying attention this morning what
actually went down what happened so
there are two different investigations
going in parallel we found out about
both of them today one is the u.s.
investigation conducted by the FBI has
been looking at some things that
happened on US soil they they got
permission to extradite from this from
the Swiss government Swiss police went
into a hotel in Zurich the other
investigation is happening in
Switzerland the Swiss government is
looking at FIFA itself so the important
distinction to draw here is that there
are many layers of FIFA there's the
executive committee that we've been
talking about but it's also composed of
Confederations South American Central
American European so the u.s. is
investigating irregularities that
happened on American soil with the South
American Confederation and the Central
American Confederation so that's where
we are right now and the question that
we're still trying to figure out is how
far up does this go these two
investigations happening in parallel
will they get to the top which is of
course Sepp Blatter Hugo Miller come in
on the topic of the arrest but also what
has been the reaction in Switzerland
well how far up is this go in answer to
Brendan's question I think a lot of
people are asking like I've been asking
today on the streets of Zurich where is
Sepp Blatter he hasn't shown up at
various Confederation meetings he didn't
show up at a press conference today and
so we have a lot of people i think
wondering what we journalists are
wondering where is the man who arguably
should be held accountable as the guy
who ran fever for the past two decades
hugo just a little bit more on the
implications and the grasp of power that
the Sepp Blatter has on FIFA
yeah what's so we here it is the man
who's been running the show here since
1998 obviously the friday election was
supposed to be a mere formality for him
he's widely seen as having secured the
support of the Africans the South
Americans the Asians and that because
FIFA operates on a country-by-country
one country one vote basis means that
even with small country support he can
sew up re-election but the trouble is is
that you now have you waifa weighing in
you a for being the European Federation
weighing in and saying hold on a second
we think we haven't yet said for sure
but we think that perhaps this vote on
friday should be postponed and this is
the Confederation represents France and
Germany and Holland and England real
football heavyweights so if they really
decided to put their foot down who knows
what will happen on Friday Hugo of
course they're two more investigations
going on in parallel we just learned a
little more detail from the one from the
FBI here in the US at a press conference
that Loretta Lynch gave about an hour
and a half ago from where you are in
Switzerland what do we know about the
Swiss investigation what are they going
after and what do they have that's one
of the things we're trying to identify
as who the who the people are that they
are talking about because as you said
the American investigations really
looking back at the past allegations of
corruption involving the gate of the
world cup of 2010 the Swiss vague
investigation is looking forward so what
we're trying to establish is who are the
people that they have not named but
they've just cited as the six that
they're looking looking into and what
roles do they play at FIFA up to the
level but just below were set bladder
sets because to stress he has not been
named or called in for questioning and
FIFA itself has been using that as
almost as an explanation or
justification to say why FIFA sorry Sepp
Blatter's is is clear and clean